do anything okay
you didn't knew enough and i'm kidding
i got into the content why would you
i got us the content that's what matters
when we were going up to that group of
girls one of them wanted to be
interviewed but the other one didn't um
what's it called when the girl started
grabbing me putting hands on me right
yeah
i would never do that to a girl because
i kind of know that you know it's just a
bit it's a bit techy if you know someone
sees that but i think in society there's
not as much of a stigma on women putting
their hands on men in generally and so a
lot of women are a lot more
okay with doing it even if the exact
same um
movement or you know action from a man
would be seen as well what are you doing
like that's that's wrong so i think
that's also another thing there's no
there's not as much stigma
yeah because modern women don't have
consequences for bad behavior because
they
i mean did you hear about that teacher
in the u.s
she slept with a 13 year old and got 60
days in jail now she's out isn't that a
movie also with adam sandler
and and even that only that only fans
model that killed her boyfriend
she she was out of jail because she's a
pretty girl
like they didn't even keep her for a
week and she's out friends
but it's like men know that there's
always going to be a consequence like if
they hit a girl they are going to jail
there's no if ands or buts but if a girl
does it to a guy
she'll get a slap on the wrist
i'll put him in perspective for y'all i
have um from that night i was describing
don't need to go into all the detail
i have a shirt that was torn off of me
right by this woman
in this country
the uk
when making allegations of assault
you have a six-month statute of
limitations never heard of that i'm from
the states it's not like that
here in this country i got a letter
from
the people who investigate the constable
area or whatever it's called here in
this country forgive me all the
outbreaks
they sent me a letter that said we are
not going to investigate because it is
outside of the statute of limitations of
six months
i got the photo from the day of with my
shirt torn off
my baby was in my hands i was holding
her like this protecting her from this
woman
right
and nothing's to happen
ever
wow
i'm sorry but some women are way too
comfortable touching men or getting
rowdy men even
the time i did in street interviews
before i did one with pearl um there was
a group of girls we interviewed and then
like these two guys came up to us and
trying to sell them like balloons and
stuff right and one girl said no and the
other one kind of said it in a rude way
so then obviously the guy started
getting agitated because he's like don't
get rude
and she's trying to match his energy and
i'm saying to the guy bro it's not worth
it just leave it like she's
she's wave let's come and he he says to
me oh you know what if you weren't here
i would have banged in the face so he
starts walking away in it and then the
girl is still acting up like no no come
back i'm just gonna
[ __ ] like
relax
i'm gonna try to die today
but he comes back and obviously starts
beefing at this point i'm just like i'm
good i'm i'm gone i did my part and
obviously he ended up um like dashing
something on the face but
he could have he could have destroyed
her like he could have done whatever she
was getting way too comfortable
i think some women don't have that
understanding or just plain common sense
that
men are
naturally stronger no matter if they
look scrawny no matter what
if you get punched by the right one you
could die
and females don't understand that they
not all females but certain females feel
like they have to
assert themselves or feel like they have
to be assertive and let their place be
known like no you disrespect me the
second third i can put my hands on you
because you did xyz i think they do that
i think the reason sometimes the reason
why
they do that is that because they know
they might get a reaction and they're
going to win the case whatever the case
is you know what i mean because they're
like oh i know you're stronger than me
i know you can hurt me so as soon as you
touch me i win but that's assuming you
survive yeah well yeah
yeah
they know they're gonna survive with the
they know in this world the the the
rules are created the world that they
live in i mean
you know let's get it straight this is a
matriarchy
there is no patriarchy in this country
this is a matriarchy but what i mean is
that she's assuming that the guy will
let her survive to you know go home
and
what if he doesn't what's going to
happen then
you can't you can't bet on that because
some guys are crazy and sometimes
gonna have that barrier and they're
gonna snap
and that's what we as men deal with
every day you never know if that guy
that you're messing with is just gonna
snap on you maybe he was crazy maybe he
was drunk
and you're gonna have to deal with the
consequences she's not thinking along
those lines she's thinking oh let me get
something for the video what do you
think of women that get in between guys
when they're fighting that's the dumbest
thing that's the dumbest thing it never
ends well have a good story about that
time so when i first came to england um
i lived in croydon and um obviously
croydon isn't exactly nice now but it
was even worse back then so um me and my
siblings were walking back from school
um and these two guys were fighting
one girl from the local secondary school
tried to get involved and try to get in
between the two guys
i turned around
to look at my sister turn back around
the girl's ear is in her hand and
there's blood everywhere
yeah because obviously one of the guys
got a knife out and tried to do
whatever and
she ended up with half her ear cut off
girls that do that i do not know what
they're doing but hey that can't be me
it could never be me
have you seen that what's that star's
name uh very big excuse me cornstar
a very big corn star uh
her fiance or husband was a
some sort of fighter and he beat the
crap out of her he's in jail now for
life
wow uh what's that cornstar's name
anyway you don't know that case
no well it's a big case it doesn't
surprise me
like a mixed martial artist or something
yeah like a professional fighter or
something and beat the crap out of her
sounds like he had a lot of attention to
get off his chest i think she was
filming she was filming something and
then they were doing it at her place and
then he found them together you know he
knew she was a corn star
uh but he got jealous i don't know i
don't know what happened
okay yeah i was never gonna work don't
you guys feel like um will smith got off
lightly for putting his hand on the map
it's not just women that sort of get
away with that what if what if chris was
a woman did you think he would have got
in the way of it
no but there wasn't a woman if
[Music]
uh violence on men the same way they
regard violence on women men are saying
men are seen as expendable in society
where women women are seen as more
valuable than men
that's why they have been do all the
hard jobs
that's why that's why women get slapped
on the wrist for everything they can
sleep with a minor they get out of it
they can
hit a man and get out of it whenever
it's against men like they just get out
of it
you know i used to get hit on by this
uh colleague of mine
and i told people i told my my singing
teacher and she's like oh i bet you love
it and every time every time we tell
someone like come on man it's fine i bet
you love the attention and